في رابع ايام شهر رمضان بلغ عدد التصاريح
الصادره عن طريق تطبيقي نسك وتوكلنا لاداء
العمره اكثر من مليونين و800 الف تصريح
فيما يستمر توافد المعتمرين والزوار على
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده اداره
المطار عملت على تحويل المزيد من رحلات
شركات الطيران الاجنبيه المنتظمه ذات
الحموله العاليه من ركاب العمره من الصاله
الشماليه الى مجمع صالات الحج والعمره
وذلك وفق الطاقه الاستيعابيه كما يستمر
المعتمرون في القدوم عبر الرحلات الدوليه
والداخليه في المطار
على كل المزيد معنا من مكه المكرمه هاني
الصيان مراسل العربيه اهلا بك هاني انقل
لنا الاجواء من عندك واخر المعلومات تفضل
نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا من مشاهدي قناه
العربيه في موقع اخر وفي جهه اخرى وتحديدا
عندما نتحدث عن المواقف التي خصصتها
السعوديه لنقل المعتمرين او ممن يرغبون من
المعتمرين الذهاب الى المسجد الحرام هذه
الحافلات وهذه المواقف تقوم بنقل معتمرين
بشكل ترددي نتحدث اليوم عن تسعه مواقف
داخل المشاعر المقدسه وخمسه مواقف خارج
المشاعر المقدسه وسوف نتحدث عن الفرق
عندما نطلع الان على هذه الصوره التي ترصد
ترصدها كاميرا العربيه من احد المواقف
المخصصه والتي خصصتها السعوديه لنقل
المعتمرين الى المسجد الحرام ونتحدث عن
مسافه لا تتجاوز
ذهاب بنقل ترددي ذهابا وايابا في وقت لا
يتجاوز العشره دقائق طبعا حافلات مجهزه
وكذلك طرق مخصصه لها اضافه الى كبائن خاصه
للتذاكر وبوابات
ذلك مساحات كبرى لتتسع لاكبر عدد من ممكن
من المعتمرين نتحدث عن اسطول حافلات ينقل
من هنا الى المسجد الحرام يتجاوز هذا
الاسطول اكثر من 1600 حافله موزعه على تسع
مواقف وكذلك هناك مواقف خارج المشاعر
المقدسه خاصه القادمين من خارج السعوديه
والذين قدموا عبر المطار وبعد ذلك
يتوجهون الى المسجد الحرام بامكانهم ان
يصلوا الى هذه المحطه وبعد ذلك ينتقلون من
حافلتهم الى الحافله
الاخرى الداخليه ايضا ممن هم قدموا من
خارج المناطق الغربيه نتحدث عن المناطق
والاخرى من السعوديه بامكانهم الوصول الى
هنا في هذه المواقف خصصت مواقف باتساع
كبير للمركبات وكذلك
بامكانهم الوقوف بمواقف مجانيه وبعد ذلك
يستقلون هذه الحافلات طبعا هذا الحافلات
اوجدتها السعوديه من اجل تقليل من كثافه
المركبات المتجهه الى المسجد الحرام وكذلك
تسهيل وصول المصلين والمعتمرين الى ايضا
المسجد الحرام او تسهيل وصولهم الى مسجد
حرام هذه الحافلات التي نتحدث فيها وهي
الحافلات القادمه من خارج المشاعر المقدسه
والتي تحمل عدد او علمتني اكثر من اعداد
كبيره من المعتمرين والذي قدموا من خارج
السعوديه او من خارج منطقه مكه المكرمه
والذين يصلون الى هذه المواقف ويصلنا هذه
هذا المكان وبعد ذلك يستقلون هذه الحفلات
التي تتجه بهم الى المسجد
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك